some great news the raiders are honoring  local health care workers by sending  them to the super bowl raiders greats  lincoln kennedy and raymond chester  joined those hometown heroes on a  virtual call  yesterday three doctors charlene adrian  orlando azir and nicholas kalika  will join nurse samantha balsomo at the  big game  in tampa this week is honored to salute  you guys for what you do you guys work  every day when the real bullets are  flying thank you  it's been a devastating past year but  this year i've got a secret  i've become a raiders fan that's a good  secret to let out right now  well the four will join 7 500 other  vaccinated  health care workers as special guests of  nfl teams  at the super bowl on sunday that is  fantastic news nate